Author and Screenwriter, Karl Iglesias: the power of story why why stories are
so important in our lives while we crave
him so much and once you understand the
power and purpose the purpose of a story
then you can write to that purpose and I
think the stories that really resonate
with audiences are stories that are that
are right on purpose as opposed to
something like if you're thinking well I
just want to entertain I just want to
have a lot of set pieces and show great
things you've never seen before well
okay that might be entertaining but you
might be missing something that's really
important in other words that story that
you're gonna be writing or filming will
be off purpose you know it's not the
purpose of a story and so audiences will
walk away with kind of like yeah that
was great but yeah you know they won't
really know they won't be able to put
you know their hand on it about why they
didn't really enjoy it or why didn't
have it didn't really resonate and that
has to do with the purpose of a story
what is the purpose of a story what is
it meant to do and so I talked about how
stories I mean every culture from the
beginning of time has had stories some
cultures may not have have created fire
some stores some cultures may not have
invented the wheel but there's not a
single culture in the history of mankind
that has never had stories so stories
are truly Universal every single culture
has had stories and why is that why
they're the shape they are why have been
telling stories up to today and still we
probably will be able to tell stories
till the end of time and that's because
they are crucial to our survival as a
species without stories we would not
have survived would not have evolved to
where we are today so I like to say that
story's gonna teach us that you just how
to survive how to live how to be human
how to interact with each other how to
change and deal with problems in the
world and stories that don't do that
fail so that's my that's my spiel about
stories
because they're part of us and I was we
evolved with stories and so stories are
part of us we our brains have evolved to
work hard what I've heard people say
there are we hardwired for stories in
other words we our brain is evolved to
appreciate stories in a certain way to
do what it's supposed to do so I like to
use the example of a sugar coated pill
you know like a kind of things like you
give to a dog and you need the dog needs
the medicine but the only way the dog is
gonna eat the pill is if it's rasa
rounded by white sugar right like to
make it really appealing stories are
that there's sugar quit pills so at the
core of a story is the the meaning the
purpose of what's supposed to do which
is to teach us a specific lesson right
and everything else is the coding to
make it entertaining in other words so
the the you know the comedy the horror
the suspend although all those emotions
that we talked about that we love that
we pay money to see are the sugar to
make it entertaining so in order to tell
a good one so you have to know how to
make it entertaining that's part of it
but you also can't miss that kernel
which is the the meaning why why that
story
what's its what what are you trying to
say with that story what's the message
you trying to say so you have to know
that because stories are lessons for us
and the only way we could relate in the
only way we could absorb that message is
to see someone experiencing what we're
supposed to learn so there's a thing
called mirror neurons which I know if
you've heard basically our brains kind
of don't know the difference between
imagination and reality so this is
something that was discovered by Italian
scientists they were studying monkeys
and trying to figure out what happens in
the brain when they do things so the
they were they were they were studying a
monkey grabbing a banana and they saw
what part of their brains lit up okay
and then they saw the brain of a monkey
watching another monkey grab a banana
and they saw that it was the same exact
firing pattern
in other words the same part of their
brain of the monkey seeing the monkey
grab a banana was the same as if the
monkey was grabbing the banana so it's
called mirror neurons there's something
we have to and the lesson of that is
that when we watch something we watch a
character in the screen going through
something our brain is thinking that
we're doing it okay
so if you're if you see a couple kissing
the same parts of the brain will light
up as you kissing someone you may not
actually feel it but it's the same part
of the brain so you're experiencing
what's going on in the screen and if a
character is struggling to accomplish
something you're by default you're
watching this ends up in a subconscious
level you are learning what the
character is learning so for me great
stories are about teaching us how to
live and the way to do that is by
showing a character who changes who
transforms and that transformation
because change is so difficult for us in
real life we need to see a character
accomplishing that change to see how
they did it and that's how we learn so
that's kind of a quick way of saying how
to tell a good story which is like show
a character who struggles to achieve a
certain goal and who transforms as a
result of that and has a great
resolution in and all that surrounded by
you know dramatic techniques that keep
us engaged because that's very important
that's another thing about that was
talking about story is that stories were
designed to feel good because it's the
way for us to pay attention to in other
words you need to make the brain pay
attention to your story in order to get
the lesson out of it and all all the
stuff about you know entertainment
that's the paying attention to in other
words when you show for example you
create suspense you know in a thriller
right your brain is doing something that
makes you pay attention that's how we
evolved to do that so you know dopamine
there's oxytocin which is
empathy drug that you're you know
mothers get that when they're babies we
get that when we hug someone
so oxytocin is a is what's called the
social or the bonding hormone because
we're social animals and so when you see
a character and you create a character
that you care about so there's actual
techniques dramatic techniques you can
use to make us care for a character then
oxytocin is going through your brain and
you bond with that character you care
about that character that's what keeps
you engaged in the story and you're
paying attention you're not disengage so
that's how you tell a good story and if
you don't know this if you don't know
how to make us care about the character
which I see that all the time
right you read scripts that don't work
you see movies that don't work because
we don't care about the character so
that already you failed if you don't
care about the character I don't care
how many bombs or set pieces or
thrilling twists you have we just don't
care about a character you're just not
gonna get the story you disengaged your
board so caring about the characters
step number one step number two is
keeping us engaged through again
dramatic techniques and hopefully you
have a purpose to your story a meaning
to your story so there's a you know when
you finish the story is finish and you
think about you go home I get it and
that's how you appreciate it that makes
the story good I think
for character and I talked about this in
my Pixar seminar so because they masters
of this you know they tell stories about
toys about monsters about bugs about
robots right you know fish rat
they make you care and connect with
those characters so there's there's a
whole bunch of techniques and and you
can see what they do and you can know
what the techniques are for me it's like
there's three three things that you do
that I that you do is is make us make us
feel sorry for that character so there's
a little moments where you can you can
create a moment in the story where a
character is unjustly abused or unjustly
mistreated or insulted or betrayed or
neglected and so it it could be any
character and if that moment is there
you're gonna feel sorry for that
character at that moment it takes an
instant so that's one if you show that
they're like us if we show their
humanity for example your show that they
care about something other than
themselves that's another technique so
there's a moment in the movie Leon the
professional which is about a hitman
right and it opens with him doing a hit
and he kills people you don't know if
he's good or bad but he goes home and he
takes care of a plant right and that
right away you say oh he cares about a
plant so he's okay he's human the other
part is admiration so this is like any
any kind of you know if you're dating
somebody or you're trying to find
somebody who's a good match for you
there's that list of lists of things
that you like in person that's admirable
trait so somebody was funny who's
responsible who's courageous it's a
whole list of things you can add to a
character to make a sale you know I
admire this usually they're like the
best at what they do they're like the
best you know the best at executive or
the best agent the best cop the best
driver
they're courageous there's a whole bunch
of a moment have hope the list the list
is all in
in the book there's all these lists of
things you can do but if you do these
three things and I when I show clips of
the of the moment you meet the character
and is usually a look at three minutes
scene you can see all these things being
applied in like three minutes there's
like you know the the opening of wall-e
after he's done with the garbage in
comes to us to his little house it's a
three minute scene and it's about twenty
of these techniques done this is how you
connect with that character in one scene
emotionally I also show a clip of a of
an ad the commercial it's a one minute
thing about a lamp whether it's a great
ad for IKEA award-winning commercial
where they make you care emotionally for
the lamp right and and the the joke
about is that the guy comes and says you
know you probably had feelings for these
lamps that bit that's because you're
crazy
the lamp has it's only a lamp it's you
know and the new one is better you know
the new lamp to replace it so but anyway
but it's great it's amazing once you
once you know those techniques and then
you see him in action you go oh my god
you know and now and I kind of always
feel I was give this caveat with to my
students and to anybody who hears me
speak that if you love stories if you
love films and you don't want me to
destroy the illusion do not listen to me
because I feel like I'm one of the
magicians who would give you the trick
of how it's done and you then you see
the trick and it's not the same anymore
so I always feel bad about that because
you know once you know the techniques
and you see a film you're gonna see him
everywhere all the time and it's gonna
kind of ruin it for you
so just fair warning right there that
you know those are those are this is how
we do it and that creates that effect
you know the lesson is don't make make
sure you make your character human let
make sure it's realistic you know
nobody's perfect right so when you have
a character who's completely perfect
that we don't really buy it but these
techniques are used for characters who
are also quote like villains for example
I was used to Sopranos Dexter Breaking
Bad as a character who's technically not
likable or they do something that carve
a moral and yet we connect with them we
care about them so that's how it's done
so
can use this on any any character the
trick about I mean the the thing about
how you do it specifically is really up
to the writer I mean I like to use to
see these techniques as tools so you
have these tools and then it's but it's
your job to apply them well you know
when you can apply them and and put all
of them in one scene it's gonna look
ridiculous so it's almost like a painter
and you have your your brushes and your
colors a few little touches here in
touches there and then the effect is is
artistic but it's up to the artist you
know and you could do it badly you could
do it good you could do it balance
that's up to you and another one that I
like to use is as good as good as it
gets
Alvin your doll I use that in my UCL
classes all the time because that's
that's a character that was purposely
created to create they'll create the
worst character ever made you know the
most disliked character New York who
falls in love with the most liked you
know sweetest waitress those kind of a
romantic comedy shows that vein and I
thought when you when you see the the
you know the first 10 15 pages of as
good as it gets is a master class and on
kazuo the I mean he's doing things that
are like horrific you know they always
say do not harm an animal and he's there
throwing the dog down the chute he
insults people he's misogynistic he's
racist you know all whatever but as soon
as he walks into that door into his to
his apartment and you get to see that he
is that he's compulsive disorder they
something is wrong with him right there
that's the first hit of feeling kind of
sorry for him you know so it could be
totally bad when you find out they're
sick you you it's it's part of us to
feel kind of story and kind of connected
and there's a whole thing with a dog
despite the fact that he threw the dog
down the chute the dog likes him yeah so
that's another thing and he takes care
of it that's another thing so gradually
we get to really like him and connect
despite his flaws traits for me is the
last thing you should worry about like
you know I know it's like this is a my
character development in how to create
characters in talk about okay make sure
you give him positive traits negative
trades but that's just one aspect of and
that's the easiest thing to do for me
it's more about how what happens to your
character and those things I've talked
about like the petty humanity and
admiration
and kind of balance the three and then
everything else you can show in that
scene or in future scenes
well the emotional core is part of a
bigger picture the reason I use Pixar is
because first I'm a huge fan of Pixar
and their stories have never been
disappointed with any of their stories I
think their master masters are telling a
story and specifically about characters
in Hutto and connecting with characters
especially since most of them are not
human but the the emotional core is
really what I called at the heart of the
story and so the heart is obviously the
character you care about but that's one
half of the equation the other part of
the equation is they're they're what I
called the worthy motivation what is it
that they trying to accomplish in the
story and why should we care in other
words usually there's an emotional stake
from that goal so for example Finding
Nemo he has to search for his son
and something we connect with we we we
think it's a worthy motivation somebody
so that's funny most everybody fish in
my in my
seminar compared to similar stories in
this case both stories about fish and
the ocean one was Finding Nemo Pixar's
and I compared with the shark tail which
is DreamWorks story and when you see
when I show the opening of a shark tail
and and the introduction of an Oscar
played by Will Smith you get you can see
the audience reaction when you compare
the two clips you know who they care
about the reason we don't really care
about Oscar in Shark Tale is because his
whole motivation is about getting rich
quick and about getting you know it's
it's something we relate to as human
beings but I've never seen a story a
film story about somebody who's trying
to get rich and that's really successful
that's appealing you know is that we
root for even though it's something that
we do we all like - we all ambitious and
trying to get rich and trying to better
our lives but you never see stories
about that why is that so because we
don't really consider we realize not
really kind of a worthy thing it's not
it's not what it life is about right
life is more about love and connecting
and
and helping your friends and if you look
at the motivations for the characters in
Pixar and have a slide with all all the
lists of all the movies that they did in
all the world motivation and 90% are
about saving the village saving a friend
rescuing a friend saving a friend saving
their mother searching for their son I
mean it's all relational so all
relationships and really the lesson you
get from all stories at least from what
I'm aware of is that it's all about
relationships about connecting with
people so it's all about love so that's
the thing about Pixar so it's oh you
make you make us connect with a
character and then we have to see them
for two hours doing something and we
really have to root for them to do that
so the when it's a worthy motivation
then we root for them and where were
connected with them and we were engaged
because of it
day one you would start with obviously
the idea what's your concept so I think
concept is important once you know your
concept and there's ways to make that
concept appealing the class I'm teaching
tomorrow morning will be on concept how
to make sure your concept is high I mean
by high concept I dunno these are
there's a term for icon set in Hollywood
but for me it means that there is high
appeal meaning that as soon as you had
the idea you go oh there's something
about it that just like hooks you and
you go wow I want to find out what it's
about or how its resolved so that's what
you should at first the next thing that
you should think about for me and I know
there's controversy about that whether
you do that first or later for me I need
to know what it's about you know what I
mean this whole story will be a
reflection of what you're trying to say
like what's your theme what's the
meaning of your story and if you don't
know what it is well you could try
developing a story and write many drafts
and then and then you figure out what it
is you go okay that's possible a lot of
writers do that and that's okay but I
always use paddy Chayefsky x' quote
which says lucky is the writer who knows
his theme from the beginning because
once you know that you've got I always
suggest you write it in big letters and
put it in front of your computer so you
see it at all times cause most of your
characters most so you've seen your
whole story will be a reflection of what
you're trying to sell your theme and so
it's better to know it right away it'll
save you a lot of time from trying to
write many drafts and then come back to
it and cut what doesn't work and create
you know new things but if you know
themes so so for me it's concept then
theme and then once you know your theme
then you can create your characters
because your character will be a
reflection especially if your character
has an arc will be a reflection of that
theme and so you know where your
character is going to start and now you
know where character is going to end and
then you can figure out your scenes and
your story in terms of all the stuff I'm
talking about character connection and
motivational and stuff those are details
that you can add later but what I'm
talking about is what the foundation of
stories which is what is your story
about and how does your character
transform to reflect that theme that
you're trying to convey
and yeah that's the foundation
there's two types of themes there's what
I call institutional themes where you
are you trying to show society you're
trying to show something that's wrong
with society or with the particular
institution the TV series the wire was
was genius at it because every season
was a specific institution that showed
the flaws of that institution and so
network was about you know the flaws of
society and and the TV TV business and
really crazy right exactly but I don't
think it was a character there that
changed or transformed in the same way
that you have you know some like Star
Wars or Finding Nemo which are very
strong with character arcs and and you
know what the character learns at the
end is you know the Epiphany of what
exactly you want to tell the audience
and so that reflects the theme well you
know King's Speech is another one I mean
there's a lot of really well received
films that if they're right on point
somatically even Star Wars is
thematically rich but we don't think
about it because we we're thinking about
you know the space out for a part of it
in a technology and the good versus evil
but there is a character arc in there
and it's an actually a thematic argument
through the story about what it's about
you know it's usually an argument
between two things and in Star Wars
it's it's technology versus the energy
the force and if you look at the scenes
and you really pay attention to what
they're talking about
even Darth Vader makes that argument in
the scenes with with his superiors with
the D whatever whoever peter cushing
plays it's not the M but the Emperor no
it's not the Emperor but whoever his
boss and all these scenes you have where
he talks about the dark side of the
force and then the other side is talking
about the power of the the Death Star of
Technology and that's the argument and
then Luke and obi-wan have the argument
about the force and only the force and
if you look at the last moment that
moment where Luke has to decide versus
the force and technology right the
targeting system and at the last second
he makes that choice that's his epiphany
that's the decision he could have kept
you know I could have chosen the other
thing it's just technology with a force
that would have been a different story
right we're saying while technology is
more important than the force in this
case Lucas wanted to show that the force
is more important technology and that's
what Luke's decision that's what he
showed and that's that was what the
audience audiences walked away from you
know
it really depends on the writer there
are writers who are okay with solitude
they're able to be by themselves from
many many hours days years and that's I
like to call it the temperament of the
artist if there are people who are meant
to be artists because they have the
right temperament for it they're able
there even though they're social animals
maybe they're okay with not being social
and so they're able to do this other
writers are not so able to do this but
you can still be writers and be in a
social environment for example I know
writers who gravitate toward television
not because now televisions the golden
age of television but because they're
more it's a more it's a more social
activity in being a TV writer you're in
a writers room you know with other
writers you create with other writers
when I was speaking to Akiva Goldsman in
for the one-on-one habits book he talked
about how he loves the balance of being
a writer and a producer he loves being a
producer because being a writer is by
himself and alone and then being a
producer he gets to be on set and being
social and be with other people so it's
a good balance so you could have 100%
all social and still be a writer you
know there's writing teams you know
Billy Wilder wrote with partners
throughout his career so there's that
social aspect of it being in the room
with somebody else and then this writers
who are okay with being by themselves
and and ripen you know alonein and kind
of being social afterwards you know with
their friends or on the set for me I'm
one of those one of those writers who
are very comfortable with their solitude
you know I mean I come from art and
artistic family and they're you know
they they're okay with you know I guess
it's genetic I'm okay with being alone
so there's a difference between being
alone and lonely this that's sure
there's a difference so you know and so
that's me
it's part of the artist makeup you know
there's I think I think certain people
are meant to be artists not because
they're creative but because they're
they're emotional being is able to
accept that you know there's no doubt
that being an artist you have to be
alone to in solitude to create unless
you
you have a partner in your doing it
together but most true artists are
solitary you know and and you're right
in in a Western society it's it's
frowned upon
you know they will see somebody who's
alone as somebody who was like you know
potential serial killer or something you
know it's just not it's frowned upon
it's how much you can take it's it
really depends on on how much do you
care about what other people say how
much do you care about that you know I
mean I see people for example you're
right somebody who dines alone in a
restaurant
surrounded by social animals and they by
themselves will know that they're
getting the stairs and the stigma and
the judgments right but if they don't
care they're gonna be okay with it it's
only people who care about now I'll be
honest with you I I care you know I mean
like I would I would not eat at a
restaurant although and even though it
probably would feel you know be great to
taste the food and enjoy the experience
but because of the fact that I know I
will be judged and negatively I try to
avoid that I also had that problem with
going to the movies alone but now it's
less now I don't care about movies but
restaurants are still care about that so
if I want to taste the food I would just
get the food to go and eat you know eat
in my place with with the actual food so
I'll get to taste the food but but yeah
because see so that's the difference
between how much do you care about how
much you're aware of what people are
thinking about you that's it because
you're right it is a negative stigma
first thing that I always want to teach
about scenes is that scenes are many
stories they're a tiny little story and
just like a story you got to think about
a beginning middle and end for a story
you got to be thinking about the point
of that story so what is the point of
that scene and usually because you want
to make it engaging you want to have
some kind of conflict in the scene so
that's why you usually scenes about one
person don't really work that much
because okay you wanted what's the
conflict unless you're talking about a
character who wants to go up the
mountain and struggles to get there okay
there's conflict there but most things
are about two people and they're usually
just like in a story about somebody
wanting something and having difficulty
getting it right there's your conflict
right there goal and obstacle Aaron
Sorkin likes to say intention and
obstacle right he doesn't started seeing
unless he knows the intention of the
character and the obstacle to that
intention once he knows those two things
he can start a scene so that's the basic
tip of it and because there are many
stories I always found that when I want
to analyze a scene a well-written scene
that it it is structure structured like
a story there's three acts to it does it
begin a millon end and therefore there's
two turning points in the scene rising
tension a climax a resolution and it's
fascinating to see in a you know two
three three minutes scene how you know
and only for the well-written scenes
there are scenes that you watch and you
go okay you know but there are some in
movies we have great scenes and those
scenes are usually full stories in that
scene so that's my advice for that
craft I mean
writer you gotta learn the craft and
only you gotta learning you got to
practice it so you will not I mean
unless you're a genius who does this
instinctively which is a possibility you
will not accomplish this in your first
script I mean if you read the 101 habits
most screenwriters who sold their script
was usually was their tenth or
fourteenth script and usually I've been
working on it for many many years so it
takes practice you know just like any
other craft takes practice and so learn
the craft and practice the craft the
other thing too you should you should
know is that there's a lot of
information out there about storytelling
about screenwriting a lot of how-to
books and you got to understand you know
I always recommend read them all you
know I mean I'm a lifelong learner I
read everything I always try to learn
you know always always always and when
you see the same thing being told and
you you got it that's what I called the
basics once you learn the basics then
you got to go beyond that right and
that's what I try to do in my writing
for emotional impact book I go beyond
the basics you know the book is
structured with all the main elements of
screenwriting you know storytelling
concept theme character story scenes
description dialogue and the first part
is the basics all the stuff that you
should know by now and now I'm gonna
teach you the craft which is what really
you should worry about which is you know
what is the effect of your writing on a
reader on an audience you know and your
audience will be a reader a reader will
be the first-year first line of defense
somebody's gonna read your script and if
they're not engaged by your writing
they're not turning the pages then you
failed you're done so you got to learn
how to do it you got to learn how to
hold somebody's attention and you got to
learn how it's done
terms of actual symptoms yeah I mean
there's there's writers who do not
understand conflict they don't know what
conflict is the right scenes that are
mostly two people talking and just
revealing exposition so it's kind of
like they just want the audience to know
certain things about their character or
their past or about the story but this
is the writers intention in the scene
not the character's intention so you get
these scenes are just basically talking
heads just exposition that's the most
boring thing there is you know we're not
we're not crap no matter how interesting
the information is so conflict lack of
goal we don't know what the character
wounds or we don't care about the
character or the scenes are just you
know what they're talking about what the
story is about is kind of cliche we've
seen that story a hundred times you know
the concept is you know what I call soft
concepts there there's nothing in the
concept to make me want to see the story
you know when you think about how you
choose to watch a movie you know usually
you see the poster or you see a tagline
or you see a trailer you can you can
tell you can like analyze how you feel
about it when you see it you know you go
you know usually for me it's the concept
when and when I know what a concept is
about when I read about a script that's
sold and they say you know story is
about this and this and this you know
you have the logline
right there I know whether the movies
gonna be successful not just from that
because it's either the laga has a hook
to it and you go oh my god that's
interesting or you know and that feeling
that huh is what that's why producers or
agent upon request your scripts because
they're just you know this the concept
is just too flat or cliche but if
something is really there's a hook to it
they're gonna at least request the
script and they're gonna read it now the
script might be flawed and it's gonna
get a pass anyway but at least I think
it's gonna be requested so if you really
have a great concept which is what I
recommend go for that make sure your
concept has a hook
there's a lot of controversy
like your love controversy is about
structure because this is something that
everybody teaches and everybody likes to
have their own version of it so you got
you know you got Michael eggs you got
Mikey you got troubie you know hero's
journey saved the cat's the key so
here's the thing about structure so I
believe in structure I think everything
in life is structured the way we
appreciate story is structured you know
it's we we are we've evolved to
understand appreciate stories because of
the way they're shaped okay so you know
my Kiva goals one for example talks
about how in the fashion industry every
shirt looks like a shirt even though it
may be a different different cut
different material whatever but a shirt
looks like a shirt that is the structure
of a shirt the structure of a human
being is the skeleton all skeletons look
the same no matter what is on top of it
right even though as human beings are
all different but the skeleton if you
rip off all of our stuff will look the
same right that means all humans beings
have the same structure if if a human
being didn't have a skeleton there'll be
like a ragdoll
piece on the on the floor right there
they would not exist the same with their
stories unstructured stories are not as
appreciated as structured stories at
least that's my experience no matter how
you label it it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what you label the
inciting event doesn't matter what you
label the beginning the middle or end
it's still structure and so all stories
are structure all stories have the same
structure not not necessarily you know
that whole thing that they teach you
which i think is ridiculous the page
numbers say okay this has to happen on
page 12 and if it's not you're doomed
now that's silly or that you have to
have an insight you know well also is
have an inciting event
that's that but the whole thing about
you know midpoints or all is lost
darkest moment and dark now there's all
this stuff there's exceptions to that
but most stories have the shape of
stories which is you know rising tension
climax resolution that's kind of in
arguable I think so I'm a big believer
in structure now in terms of the actual
labels that's up to you to decide I mean
the way I learned structure was to
basically read everything and to really
kind of like learn what other people
have said from the beginning and kind of
if it didn't resonate with me then I
didn't absorb it but there's there's
always something where you something
does resonate with you and you suddenly
understand it and so you adapt that to
your own work to your own term lessons
your own craft so you know my my labels
for structure might have little pieces
from all the different ones from that
has been taught so far and that's what
works for me doesn't this one mean that
it would work for someone else you know
so it's up to you up to the writer to
really study all forms and really
understand why that is that's the most
important thing and when you think about
stories when I talk about the power of
stories I kind of show why stories are
shaped to where they are it's kind of
the way where we're conditioned to
accept them and if they're not there
which that was weird that doesn't fit it
doesn't seem like a story or something
and so something will be missing and
that's I think that's that happens a lot
from writers who don't know structure or
try to say well structure doesn't exist
or whatever negative connotation
therefore structure which is oh it's
gonna make me own creative and it's
gonna be like cookie cutter formula and
all the stuff people say about structure
well I do show a slide of human beings
that look different and when you take
away all the stuff and you show
skeletons those skeletons look the same
so you can Arg argue that human beings
don't or don't have the same structure
they do have the same structure but they
all look different
it's the same with stories stories all
have the same structure but they all
look different
I mean one of the things about
storytelling is that we respond to new
we were conditioned to respond to new
things to pay attention to new things
that's what we like high-concept part of
it is like what I call the uniquely
familiar we you you have to come up
something unique we've never seen before
that's also familiar you know there's
this joke about the executive saying
yeah just give me the same thing only
different all right probably heard this
before that's what it means
we want to we want to see stories that
are different but familiar it's all the
same thing but in a different way
different angle so the thing with
characters is that you know as we see
more more characters in more and more
stories we have to come up with
something that's new we have to come up
with new characters or new traits or new
goals or and that's getting harder and
harder and harder so because of that I
think they're becoming more complex
I think we're because of all the
entertainment that's been done good
storytellers are aware of that and by
the way to answer your previous question
about beginning writers one of the
things that the reason we see a lot of
material we've seen before you know kind
of like cliche stuff is because they're
not aware of what's been done before so
part of your education as a writer is
really to know what's been done before
so you've really got to be very
knowledgeable about you have to be kind
of to be a geek about this about knowing
all the movies that have been done
before and all the TV that's been done
before and all the comic books have been
done before so that you know when you
create something you try to avoid that
come up with something unique
know there's nothing new Under the Sun
everything has been done before but
there's there's always I'm always amazed
I'm always excited when when there's a
new concept or something like you know
my god that's such that's brilliant you
know because it's familiar but it's
unique you know so it's it's you know so
there's always that it's all about
creativity and originality and that's
really a big part of being an artist you
have to be original that's why we
respond to
hahaha absolutely we're probably the
biggest progressed inators there is and
and the only reason for that is because
writing is hard
creating is hard yeah I mean I'm
probably the biggest foot press
innovator there it is we you know every
writer will relate to the experience of
you know trying to do anything else but
right you know the whole thing about
sharpening your pencils and doing your
laundry and cleaning your house and you
know answering emails or playing
solitaire you know on one hand it's
something that's advised because there
is that whole thing about the creative
process where you know we're talking the
gestation period where you're supposed
to think about your problem your
creative problem and then kind of ignore
it and do something else that's
unrelated
that helps creatively so people think
okay that means procrastination you can
do other things and there is some truth
to it the problem is is if you're
constantly afraid to write and so you're
trying to do other things then you'll
never write because you're just
constantly procrastinating so there's
got to be a point where you you've got
to put that aside and actually write so
you got to get over it and it's plenty I
mean online there's tons of advice about
procrastination and how to avoid it
because it's not just for writing it's
for everybody everybody procrastinate
you know anything that's worthwhile to
do and it's scary to do people will
procrastinate I think it's very you said
that fear is more what's at stake not
writer's block that there really isn't
writer's block
there isn't any right please don't
believe that I could be I'm wrong but I
think it's fear it's it's fear of fear
of success fear of failure fear of being
judged negatively fear of being be
embarrassing yourself you know those are
certainly old fears that I relate to and
that you know I have to overcome well
why do you think we put the label of
writer's block on it like I've heard
some people say well you know I'm
currently blocked right now right and
it's like it's an affliction cuz it
sounds good
I mean I second - oh well right lucky
artists I'm a real artist because I've
writer's block or but block just really
means you're not writing it just means
you're the words are not coming up and
there is the words are not coming up
because fear is creating an attention
that prevents you from from writing you
know that's what it is so you know it's
like saying you know a plumber or a
plumber and that doesn't have plumbers
block all right this has got to do their
job it's right doing it's about doing
your job showing up at your at your job
you have to understand that writing is a
job well you get paid or not you got to
show up to your desk and you got to put
your butt on the chair and you gotta
type words you know so that's what it is
and so we used as an excuse we say well
it really is fear of writing fear of
whatever all those procrastinating
things I've said but it doesn't sound to
say oh I'm afraid it sounds a lot better
to say I'm blocked because then people
can go home for you oh yeah you're
you're an artist you know so it sounds
better but it's really it's just fear
you know and again there's plenty of
material out there about how to overcome
those fears so it's all psychological
stuff you just have to overcome
and it's usually because you know the
writing they didn't respond to the
writing as much as they wanted to
they've really expected the pat on the
back and being told how great it was and
chances are it wasn't as good so really
it's up to you it depends on how thick
your skin is it's about how much you
want this and how much you were
conscious enough to understand that
feedback is important and that you
should take it as it is you should look
at as constructive criticism and and pay
attention to it and rewrite and make it
better it's all about making it better
and you really got to know how to do it
it's big part of the Hollywood job you
know as a screenwriter you mean you know
I've never heard of something being just
first draft you know it's always draft I
mean you know thirty drafts forty drafts
you know so they're constantly and you
got to be able to do that if you're the
type of writer who does not like to be
told that something is wrong and wants
to say no this is the way it is it's my
art and that's what it is you shouldn't
be writing screenplays you should be
writing novels or plays that's really
the only two professions where the
writer is king really unless you doing
television I guess television the writer
is king there but but mostly novelists
and playwrights where yeah the editor
can tell you something's not working and
you can take it or leave it but it's
really you you have the final say on it
then you should do that but you know I
think people who have think skins or
very sensitive about creative feedback
should not be screenwriters I mean
they're in for a really you know very
frustrating experience if that's the
case
if you're an aspiring writer and you
finish your screenplay always make give
it give it to as many people as you can
to read and get feedback on very
important when it gets to the point
where you know the only feedback you get
is wow this is great
I would love to see this movie then you
can start marketing it and so there's
different ways you can do I mean you can
you can try to meet agents producers
Network go to events try to query you
know I I talk in the book about that
one-on-one habits how query letters is
is you know anybody who who tells you to
do career leaders don't listen to them
because that's not how it works so it's
really word of mouth it's all about
recommendations so you know an agent
will read your script if it's
recommended by somebody they trust so
you have to give it to somebody they
trust you know so it's really about
knowing people and the more people you
meet in Hollywood or LA the better
because then you can network in that
sense for people who are afraid of that
who are not social and have a tough time
making relationships I always advise to
enter a contest because that's that's
the easiest way you just enter a contest
preferably a reputable one like the
nickel or Austin Sundance I mean there's
a lot of them but there's only a few
that rip reputable I don't think anybody
cares if you want some really minor
contests and and I gotta say when I when
I was working in development I use we
used to read the winners of certain
contests because it's because we like
the concept but the the scripts were not
good there were flawed even though they
won the contest so it's really about the
competition of you know you're competing
against so so enter reputable contests
and if it's really good if your script
is really good it will rise to the top
that's always believe in creme rising to
the top so rise to the top and then
people will request the script so it's a
good way to have your script read by
others if it's really good so enter as
many concepts as you can get feedback
and see what happens that's the only or
if you wanna do it by yourself if you
want to raise the money by yourself and
do Kickstarter campaigns and make your
movie that's fine too you can do it
you know but get feedback first because
there's a lot of writers who like I said
before are not are too sensitive
to feedback and so they try to avoid
feedback they try to think that their
stuff is really great and they try to do
everything possible to make that movie
and they raise money and whatever and
they finally do it that's great and then
it fails because it wasn't that good and
audiences don't respond to it and you
just wasted all this time and money and
energy so feedback is paramount
understand about dialogue is that it's
got to be connected to the characters
desire line in the scene in other words
it if we character has an objective your
intention in the scene the dialogue has
to match that intention and what I see a
lot of times especially with exposition
and information is that a character is
saying all that information and you can
tell that it's really the writers
objective in other words the writer once
- once the audience to know this
information because they think okay the
audience needs to know this and this and
this and this so the characters gonna
say this in this business and that
doesn't work because scenes and dialogue
are about a character's intention in the
scene everything a character says is
matched to what that desire line is so
anything that doesn't belong to that
doesn't fit and you can tell whether
it's the writer wanting to let
information wanting the audience not
information whether it's part of the
character a certain thing of an example
so one of the best questions you can ask
yourself for every single line of
dialogue in your scene so write the
dialogue first draft just do what you
want to do don't worry about that but
when you reread the dialogue ask
yourself for every line why is that
character saying this why is the
character saying that specific line most
of the time will be because they're
responding to what so they're reacting
to something that's fine but a lot of
the times you will find that a character
is saying something because you want the
character to say that not because the
character wants something in that scene
at a specific time so you've got to know
what the character wants and then every
line of dialogue is a strategy for that
character to get what they want and if
that dialogue is not that then you
rewrite the line until it fits that now
exposition there's ways to make sure the
exposition and your dialogue matches the
objective for example if
you know I'm suspected of murder and
you'reyou're the you know detective
who's asking me questions right and tell
me where were you and I didn't commit
the murder
well whatever I'm gonna say is my desire
to make you think I didn't do the murder
so there is an there's a reason why I'm
saying that line I didn't do it I was at
the movies
saying at the movies is exposition but
it's connected to my desire to convince
you that I was not the killer
you see so the exposition matches the
objective of the character you know so
there's ways to do this displaying it
you know there's techniques to make sure
the exposition is settled you know part
of a part of conflict part of your
desire line etc there's a lot of stuff
you could do but that's the lesson you
really have to know that's the that's
the most important thing make sure you
know what every character once in the
scene make sure that what they say
matches that objective so I always bring
out David Mamet was you know genius at
dialogue and he said once nobody says
anything unless they want something so
unless you want something nobody says
anything because nobody's gonna say you
know hey I'm a trustworthy character
right I mean if somebody said that to
you you know kind of you want to be
thinking whoa why is he telling me this
right there's always a reason why so
there's always a reason and if we know
what the reason is in the movie if you
know what the character wants or you
trying to figure out what the character
ones that's more interesting then
somebody dumping exposition you know
characters would just dump exposition
it's just boring because it's not it's
not connected to a desire line even
characters who disagree with each other
even though that might be kind of
interesting because there's some tension
there if if we don't know what they want
it's gonna be boring so you see you see
this a lot with amateur scenes of people
like oh I need a conflict so my
characters are just gonna argue and so
you have the people arguing back and
forth but it doesn't doesn't mean
anything it's just right because we
don't know what they want that's really
what makes something interesting is in
tension and
obstacle to that I like to talk a lot
about contrast so you have two
characters in the scene it's really
always more interesting if the
characters are contrasted so if a
character is speaking in a formal way so
somebody was an academic or a professor
or doctor a nice piece in a formal way
make sure that the person that he's
interacting with speaks in a more slangy
way or you know more contracted way
because that's gonna make you're gonna
create that contrast you know just like
in painting if you you want to highlight
the color blue you surround it with
yellow right it's opposite so it's the
same thing with characters a lot of the
techniques in in the dialog chapter in
the book are about individuality how do
you create individual voices cuz having
all the character sound the same is a
very common problem with dialogue it's
usually the writers voice and you know
and you know Sorkin has actually been
criticized for that that all these
characters sound the same but you know
when I when I talk about his dialogue
and I show clips and actual scripts you
can show that you know he actually does
individualize and the characters sound
different so it's an unfair criticism
but but you have to do that you know it
helps if if there's some you know
difference in character speech or
cadence or contractions versus you know
stilted
writing grammatically correct training
why is connected to curiosity and I
think all great artists are highly
curious individuals for me I'm just I'm
just curious about everything so the
reason I love writing so much is because
you know just like learning about it
something I mean I I'm not the first one
to say this but I write about things
that fascinated me because I don't know
I don't know about I mean I was our
write in order to learn I write in order
to learn more about a topic and and you
know answer that why question why is
this done or how or whatever so but the
why in terms of writing connects to the
reason why characters do what they do
that's what audiences really want to
know and that comes to motivation
so what efficient is really important I
mean it's it's the cliche actors a
question right like what's my motivation
why do i why am I doing this why am i
saying this in a scene well when you're
writing a story and you're creating a
character and you have all these things
happening in the story that you've come
up with so he's going to do this is
going to do that and this is gonna
happen you got to know why audiences
really want to know why because if it's
if it doesn't connect to a universal
motivation it's gonna feel contrived and
fake and that happens all the time what
happens with you go son
you know what that character would not
do that what you know and you might be
true about that you know so for me why
connects to motivation you know it's
like once I know what a character wants
the next question is why and you better
have a good answer to why a character
wants what they want why did they react
a certain way you know which creates the
plot it's all comes to character and
social psychology you know how original
the writing is how much of a world is
explored right because you know somebody
who's not really curious about something
it'll be flat because you only get like
it's just a certain level of material
right whether it's one-dimensional
characters
right be just like one surface of a
character because that you didn't go
deeper as to the research or knowing
about the character or their psychology
so that's I feel I feel that that you
know when you come across stories that
are really rich and deep you can tell
the writer was very curious because they
you know they dug deep and that's why
they explored so Silence of the Lambs a
perfect example yeah I mean look at all
the richness of detail of character
character psychology even that world The
Godfather perfect example yeah I mean
justjust you can tell the artists that
are really curious about the world
they're writing in and the characters
you know those who really write truly
true that three-dimensional characters
and great complex relationships and you
know yeah so that's that's how it
affects it you know and not everybody is
curious so that's why you have good
writers and bad writers originality
comes from being curious because the
more curious you are about something the
more you know about something and so the
more you can avoid copying something
right is I think the people who write
cliche who have cliche writing because
they don't know what's been done before
so they go to them it's new and they go
oh they think it's good but people who
know and they've seen it a hundred times
because they're curious will say it's
cliche because they've seen it a hundred
times
that is actually the bane of the writers
exist especially the screenwriter to
come up with something new I mean when
you think about I think in in the the
second edition of the 101 habits bill
marsilii one of the one of the
screenwriters there talks about doing
the 20s so for him like everything that
he thinks about any event any scene
character whatever he thinks of kind of
listing 20 different ways of doing it
like if it's like a you know talk about
the meet-cute writing in romantic comedy
how people meet in a cute way
well he's gonna do 20 different thoughts
about it okay they can mean this I mean
you have to do he does 20 because the
the first two or three or five of them
will be cliches will be things that you
know your automatic gonna think about
him because they're the most famous ones
are the most that we've seen a hundred
times but but going deeper and he forces
himself to go deeper that's where you
get the creativity and the originality
and eventually when you reach that past
the 10 or 12 15 all the way up to 20
you'll start getting some really
original ways because you force yourself
and so that's that's what the writer
needs to do you got to force yourself to
go deeper in order to create some
original writing so try it as a game
it's a it's a it's a tip that he uses as
a you know habit of creativity to just
do the 24 anything you know 20 different
ways to rob a bank 20 different ways to
to say I love you 20 different ways to
break up with someone join different
ways to kill someone I mean there's all
these things that you've seen a hundred
times and when you see it over and over
you go you know you're you go huh you
know cuz you've seen it a hundred times
and it's only the really the movies that
break out stories the stories that break
are the ones that are kind of truly
original right
the thing you should be aware of is
human dynamics you know psychology
emotions character relationships that
you should be well-versed in now lucky
is the writer who has had an amazing
life experience and had all those
experiences that he can write about that
makes it easier but it's not necessary
if you're a highly curious person I mean
you know you could be a great writer
who's had a very mediocre life you know
I mean I'm not I'm not a believer of the
Hemingway thing about you know if you
want to write about adventure you got a
you got a go and be adventurous and
stuff I mean there may be some truth to
it but I think it really depends on your
mind and your curiosity you know and I
think we can all find you know it's all
about your imagination if you have if
you're highly imaginative you can you
can worry about anything whether you
experience it or not you know if you
write science fiction you know George
Lucas then didn't experience going on a
ship in order to be able to write about
it right or James Cameron you know do
you think he do you think all the stuff
of a Pandora and Avatar that he
experienced in his own life no it's all
imagination right so that's what you
need you need you need to know you need
to have high imagination obviously but
then you need to know be well-versed in
character relationships so yes if you've
had experience recurrency relationships
that's great and character complex but
if you haven't you can always learn it
and if you're highly curious you know I
mean I've a psychology degree so if I
wasn't a writer I'd be a psychologist
because that's what fascinates me I'm
fascinated by human interactions human
psychology and especially the reason why
people do what they do which is what
characters doing stories so really you
know that works for me but my life story
as much as it was it I considered very
unique and different from most people's
life stories I don't have the desire to
write about it so it doesn't affect me
at all in that in that sense